[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute habe ich ein richtig leckeres
kuren rezept für euch und zwar gibt es
einen amerika oft kochen
ich hab hier im prinzip meinem
russischen zupfkuchen abgewandelt habe
eine maritime börse boden gemacht hier
oben drauf natürlich auch noch andere
teenie kekse und mandeln also amerika
sind kleine italienische kekse und die
sind wirklich super lecker und innen
drin sind noch ein paar aprikosen stücke
und es ist wirklich ein super saftiger
kuchen superschnell gemacht und vor
allem finde ich es schön man hat drei
komponenten dh den boden die creme und
daneben noch die streusel aber man hat
nur eine zubereitungs schritte und zwar
boden und streusel ist dieselbe masse
ich zeige euch jetzt zuerst einmal die
streusel masse und dafür die zutaten die
wir benötigen verspachtelt aber egal ob
für den boden und die streusel brauche
ich 250 gramm martini kekse 200 gramm
kalte butter 250 gramm mehl 75 gramm
zucker eine prise salz und einen
teelöffel backpulver zuerst kümmere ich
mich jetzt um die kekse stadt am maritim
könnt ihr zum beispiel auch spekulatius
verwenden und die werden jetzt einfach
zerkleinert ich nehme jetzt dafür hier
diese reise ihr könnt sie aber auch
gerne in gefrierbeutel freien füllen und
dann mit dem nudelholz draufschlagen
eine handvoll der keks habe ich jetzt
übrig gelassen die brauche ich nämlich
später für die deko die kekse gebe ich
jetzt in einer schüssel rhein und die
braucht jetzt auch dafür keine
küchenmaschine und auch dem
handrührgerät denn ich werde das die
streusel maße einfach mit den händen
zusammenfügen
also jetzt kommen einfach noch die
restlichen zutaten mit rein butter mehl
zucker und backpulver und salz und jetzt
könnt ihr die zutaten entweder mit der
hand oder mit einem teig zur hacker kurz
vermischen
[Musik]
jetzt fühle ich zwei drittel der straße
in meinen vorbereiteten back ring den
ich bereits auf 26 cm eingestellt und
das ist wirklich eine ganz tolle masse
ich benutze jetzt nämlich einmal für den
boden und einmal für die streusel und
jetzt könnt ihr euch hier die masse am
boden fest drücken und auch einen
kleinen rand nach oben ziehen
[Musik]
der boden ist jetzt bereit den stelle
ich kurz zur seite und werde jetzt in
der zwischenzeit schon mal die füllung
zubereiten und seine freunde die
restlichen zutaten für die füllung
brauche ich 5 150 gramm zucker 750 gramm
quark 200 gramm schwand 70 gramm butter
einen teelöffel vanille extrakt 30 km
stärke eine dose aprikose den saft einer
halben zitrone orangenschalen abrieb
hier habe ich noch 30 gramm gehobelte
mandeln und für die deko später etwas
dekor schnee okay es ist eine dose
aprikosen aber dose aprikose hat sich
halt gut geräumt eine dose afrikas und
die eier dazu also für die füllung
nehmen jetzt die eier
die kommen jetzt in die schüssel werden
gemeinsam mit dem zucker ein wenig
schaumig gerührt
so schaue mich ein neuer mast gebe ich
jetzt noch den marker quark dazu und
höre auch dance band die flüssige butter
dass vanille extrakt und die stärke 1
[Musik]
zum schluss verfeinere ich die füllung
noch mit dem zitronensaft und mit der
abgegebenen orangenschale und jetzt
fühle ich die creme hier in den
tortenring
[Musik]
aber ich finde wir sollten auch nur ein
zebra käsekuchen machen damit man immer
schoko und weiß im wechsel das ist okay
so der restplätze zum ausschläge ich mal
so ich mag käsekuchen
ich weiß noch wie es euch geht aber ich
schreibe gern aus jetzt nehme ich die
aprikosen die habe ich bereits fein
gewürfelt
ihr könnt natürlich auch für sich nehmen
oder mandarinen alles was ihr möchtet
ihr künstler braucht gerne weglassen
aber ich bin die bringen noch mal so ein
bisschen frucht mit ein bisschen
feuchtigkeit und ich mag frucht ganz
gerne wärmer kann auch zum beispiel
rosinen nehmen und die vorher in rom
oder apfelsaft trinken und die mit rein
geben die variante gibt's doch das
sollte auf jeden fall reichen den rest
werden wir einfach in unseren ob salat
geben
jetzt kommen hier noch die streusel
drauf und wer möchte kann jetzt hier
noch die geholten mandeln mit rein geben
[Musik]
ibc noch ein paar amara teenie drauf die
können jetzt im ganzen oder ganz grob
zerbröselt drauf geben der zupfkuchen
wird jetzt im vorgeheizten backofen bei
170 grad ober unterhitze etwa 70 bis 80
minuten gebacken
[Musik]
um festzustellen ob der zupfkuchen
fertig ist will ich ganz vorsichtig an
blech und er sollte dann aussehen wie
ein fester wackelpudding anschließend
kann ich dann direkt den torten rahmen
lösen und den zug und vollständig
abkühlen lassen
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt den suff kuchen
vollständig abkühlen lassen und die dann
auch noch für eine stunde in den
kühlschrank gestellt damit er jetzt
schon kalt ist und ich habe ihn dann
anschließend mit etwas dicker schnee
bestreut das ist ein schnee da einfach
nicht drauf schmidt für ein richtig
schöner puderzucker und jetzt wieder
angeschnitten da freue ich mich schon
die ganze zeit drauf lecker knuspriger
boden
ach warum der geiz ich mache einfach
großes kuchenstück
[Musik]
bereits das sieht nicht gut aus
der rc durch discos und wisst ihr was da
jetzt noch der oberhammer wenn wir jetzt
noch sondern selbst gemachte kompott
macht was orange und aprikose und desto
darüber träufeln lässt mega leider
leider ich sage es noch mal leider ist
der murat nicht da ich gerade auf reisen
ganz weit weg in china daher muss ich
mich jetzt opfern und diesen zug kuchen
für euch probieren auch da nicht so
lecker nach orange martini herz reden
[Musik]
sein schuss geht
okay das kann ich euch nichts antun ich
muss er natürlich verraten wo ist das
rezept gibt falls ihr diesen leckeren
kuchen auch machen möchte dann schaut
auf meinem blog vorbei auch sallys -
blog.de da steht noch mal alles ganz
genau für euch verfeinern könnt ihr den
kuchen und die masse übrigens auch gerne
mit etwas amaretto dann schmeckt er
kuchen einfach viel viel mehr nach
amerika nie aber ich finde ihn so
einfach schon richtig perfekt und ich
verabschiede mich jetzt von euch setze
mich hin dass noch ein café raus und wir
sehen uns das nächste mal bis dann die
jungs kommt vorbei es gibt leckeres
essen
ok jungs und an die träger
[Musik]